hi I'm Maddie Ziggler and this is the
wired autocomplete
interview this is so weird I've like
watched these videos so now like holding
it in person is really
[Music]
funny what is Maddie Ziggler's job I am
a dancer and an actor and a few other
things in
between what brand does Maddie
Ziggler own I don't own a brand I'm like
trying to think no I don't own a brand
but not for long no I'm just kidding I I
don't hopefully I'll own a brand in the
future what is Maddie Ziggler signature
move I feel like it's changed throughout
the years I think when I was younger I
did this switch leap which I feel like
if anyone has seen it on the show that I
was on growing up but I think what
became more signature was when I like
pulled my eye in the Chandelier dance I
did like a thing like that in behind the
curtain I feel like that was like a
signature thing what makes Maddie
Ziggler unique in the Dance World my
emotion and the way that I have used
characters in my different dance pieces
is what made me stand out to seea and
why I got that job in the first
place who was Maddie Ziggler and Pretty
Little Liars oh my gosh that is such a
flashback I don't even know if I had a
character name I was like a ghost or a
spirit or something that was truly at
the time one of the best days of my life
because I was such a Pretty Little Liars
fan what has Maddie Ziggler been in I
would say more recently you would know
me for maybe a film called The Fallout
that I did or I have a new film coming
out called fitting in Westside Story
what is Maddie Ziggler favorite song
that's like asking a mom to pick her
favorite child I feel like I don't know
I don't know if you can do that I feel
like a song that's on heavy rotation is
Sweet Thing by Mary J BL she didn't
originate the song I don't think but I
think it's her cover Maddie Ziggler
Velma dancing I played Velma and
Westside Story and we got to perform the
iconic dance at the gym scene from the
original film and it was such an
incredible moment it was obviously
directed by Steven Spielberg and it was
choreographed by Justin peek and I was
so lucky to work with both of them I
think six or seven days to film just
that one dance scene it was a huge
production what
makeup does Maddie Ziggler I'm scared
where this is going use oh I use so many
different brands of makeup I think
there's so many different amazing
products for different things I think
Charlotte Tilbury is great say beauty is
great hourglass I have a bunch of
different favorites for sure what is
Maddie Ziggler zodiac sign I'm a Libra
I'm like not super into signs but when
people who are and they know that I'm a
Libra they're like that makes so much
sense traits of a Libra are just like
super go with the flow pretty calm
indecisive which I all those things when
did Maddie Ziggler start dancing I
started dancing when I was 2 years old
and I started competitively dancing when
I was four so real early when was Maddie
Ziggler on Dancing With the Stars that
was weird I did not know that was going
to happen I performed on Dancing With
the Stars a few times I did a
performance with CA and Allison Hulker
who's an incredible dancer and then I
think I performed with Josh Gro
on there and then I also did a
performance with my sister when she was
on Dancing With the Stars Jor I did a
little guest Trio performance and it was
so much fun oh I also did another
performance with Allan and Alexa's
friend all of the pro dancers on the
show are incredible I think Val and
Jenna they're a married couple and
they're absolutely incredible I would
love to train with both of
them is Maddie Ziggler on Mas dancer
wrong Ziggler my sister was but I wasn't
does Maddie Ziggler like Jenna Ortega I
love Jenna ortea she's one of my
greatest friends and she's a little
angel and I adore her I adore working
with her but I also just adore our
friendship and I think it's really
special did Maddie Ziggler perform at
Coachella I did I recently performed at
Coachella this year with Labyrinth and
CA and it was such a fun experience it's
so crazy for how many times I've
performed actually get nervous every
time before I go on stage but I think
it's more excitement nerves it's that
Adrenaline Rush it's just that feeling
of like the anticipation of going on
stage but the second I hit the stage I'm
so comfortable does Maddie Ziggler have
tattoos I do I have a lot of little
tattoos I think I have about seven
they're all really small cuz I wanted to
make sure that uh for acting purposes
that it would be easier to cover cuz
it's not fun to have to sit in that make
makeup chair a lot longer to get a bunch
of tattoos covered up but also I love
the look of dainty ones and shout out to
Dr Woo because he's done all my tattoos
and I love him because I'm indecisive I
didn't want to do anything that I knew I
would regret later in life and I know a
lot of people do end up regretting a lot
of their tattoos so I make sure that all
of my tattoos are really like personal
and sentimental so the first tattoo I
got was my grandma who passed away I got
her name in cursive and it's also my
sister's middle name so it's like a
double meaning Maddie Ziggler bloody
hell so bloody hell is the original
title name of a film that I did that
premiered itself South by Southwest and
now it is called fitting in which will
be premiering next year in theaters
which is so exciting I adore the film
and put so much of my heart into it and
I can't wait for people to see
it thank you how did Maddie Ziggler
became famous become famous I guess on a
reality show when I was 7 years old it's
so weird cuz I hate saying that I'm
famous I think it's just like a really
weird concept for me so yeah but I guess
that's how I got my
start how many turns can Maddie Ziggler
do it depends
because regularly I think I've been able
to do probably like 10 turns but uh when
you wear a tap shoe you can actually do
more turns so I maybe I don't know
probably 18 like consecutive pure wets I
can turn for hours how many siblings
does Maddie Ziggler have
there's lots of those my sister and I
are the only blood and then there's
seven other ones how many crowns does
Maddie Ziggler H oh I'm sorry
I don't know I I think I had around like
13 12 or 13 it's so funny because you
work your whole life when you're younger
for these crowns and they're all just
like these plastic tiaras that actually
don't mean anything so it's really funny
how much I cared about it when I was
younger but yeah they're not not
important now but at the time how old
was Maddie Ziggler oh my gosh I'm sorry
in Chandelier I'm ruining this whole
board I was 11 years old when I did
chandelier what's funny is when I was
filming chandelier I remember I flew to
LA and did it and had the best time but
when I came back to my dance studio I
told all my friends just this little
video that's going to come out no one
will see it I was like I wore a blonde
wig like it was really different and
weird at the time and I never expected
it to blow up the way that it did this
is so much easier than I thought it
would be I thought
okay Maddie
Ziggler costumes I have lots of those my
mom has kept almost all of our Dance
Competition costumes and she has them in
a closet but I'm so happy I have all I'm
like you can never get rid of them like
the important ones especially because I
want to be able to look back on them
when I'm older and I don't know I want
my kids to see them I don't know if I
have a favorite there's so many to
choose from a lot of my lyrical solos
that I did were really beautiful
costumes with a lot of rhinestones and I
liked them a lot Maddie Ziggler
imagination palette yeah I was so
excited to do a makeup collaboration
makeup is one of my absolute favorite
things in the world so getting to create
my own palette all of the shade names
and the colors and the textures and just
even the whole creative for the shoot
was so much fun and I had such a great
experience when I was creating the shade
names I think it was kind of a mixture
of playing into the concept of the
imagination palette and then also I
think just a few personal names and
things like I I named a shade after my
mom after my sister so stuff like that
Maddie Ziggler knee drop that was also a
very I guess signature move that I used
to do which is so funny cuz if I did
that now my knees would probably break
basically you start on one leg and dive
onto the other leg and you land on your
knee but the trick is to obviously
protect your knee and to land more on
the side of your hip Maddie Ziggler
podcast
I had a podcast with my sister called
take 20 for a bit and that was really
fun we had a great time doing that and
then I've had the pleasure of being on a
few other people's podcast they're so
fun it's such a good way to have a
conversation and dive into some topics
that maybe you wouldn't on the everyday
basis Maddie Ziggler to all the boys oh
my gosh this is hilarious I made a
little cameo in one of the to all the
boys movies I think it was the second
film yeah that I think I played a cheer
later I had like one line but it was fun
I I love Lana Condor I think she's so
cute and sweet and super talented and
yeah it was
fun I actually can breathe now cuz I
thought that was going to be way more
stressful and I thought you guys were
going to expose me in a lot of ways no
it's so interesting that a lot of people
still want to know what like my favorite
signature dance moves are and stuff like
that I think it's really
[Applause]
cool